all right guys
bang bang i've got andy here with me uh
thanks so much for doing this
thank you for having me for sure uh so
for the like two people who are watching
this who don't know who you are
let's just start with your background
and kind of what you did before
you got to wealthfront okay well i was a
career venture capitalist for almost 25
years
the last 10 of which i co-founded
and was a general partner of benchmark
capital and then i retired the beginning
of o5
to teach at stanford graduate school of
business where i've continued to teach
and then in december of 2011 we launched
the wealthfront service so that was
quite an accident
and i'm the founder and ceo co-founder
and ceo of wealthtrack
awesome uh so one of the things i'm
personally interested in
is what was the uh genesis for starting
benchmark right you'd already spent a
bunch of time adventure but
what was the uh the idea or the impetus
uh for when you guys started that
well i needed a job
that's a pretty good answer
i had the good fortune to have been a
partner
at another one of the at what was then a
premier
firm in the venture business called
merrell pickard anderson and i
was probably one of the top five or six
firms in the business
and two of our five partners
had reached an age where they wanted to
retire and that
left three of us and we could either
have taken the franchise forward
or we could start something new
and so two of we decided on the latter
so we wound down merrell pickard our
last fund
our 1989 fund was a 10x fund
and in 1989 that was a big deal
so in 95
actually new year's eve 94 we five of us
shook hands to start
benchmark so it was my partner one of my
partners from merrell pickard bruce
dunleavy and i
and three other people the other
partner the third partner from merrell
pickard
teamed up with two other people and
started foundation
capital and at the same time another one
of the top five venture firms
tvi had decided i had the same
generational transition where the
founding partner was going to retire
and uh one of their partners joined us
bob cagle who was one of our co-founders
and that left two partners from tvi and
they teamed up with one other person and
started
august capital so from the two firms
were created three that's awesome
um and then the name benchmark uh
there's a lot of speculation
what what did uh what was the idea
behind the name
well we wanted something we had uh read
a book
that we were heavily influenced by at
the time that we had come together
called built to last and so we wanted a
name
that evoked something that was built to
last we were looking for an
architectural term and believe it or not
benchmark was initially
the high point in a in a building
and we also wanted something that had a
technology connotation
and back in the days of hardware you
always benchmarked
your products against everyone else's so
when we came upon that name we just
loved it because it had the
the double entendre and that's and the
best part of all
was the domain name was available in
1995 that was
you know you could get a name like
benchmark.com
so that was the the final straw that led
us to move forward
that's awesome and obviously uh the
reputation speaks for itself in terms of
you guys ended up going on and built
uh one of if not the number one venture
capital firm
in the technology industry um and
you did it for about a decade if i
understand correctly uh
what was the fascination or kind of drew
you to
teaching right i think a lot of people
said you know hey
that is a natural progression but what
was it for you personally in terms of
wanting to go do that
well i wanted to give back you know i
have a life beyond anything that i
ever could have imagined and i wanted to
give back
to the institutions that made that
possible so
i became a trustee of my undergrad alma
mater university of pennsylvania
where i got to know howard marks who we
were discussing before we started
very uh well we actually served on the
endowment investment board together
and then i started teaching at stanford
graduate school of business where i got
my master's degree
uh i had and then my wife and i started
an innovative cancer research funding
initiative
and so they were all things to give back
and uh
teaching just sort of came naturally i
was at
i t a lot of courses undergrad and grad
i
was a guest lecturer for a number of
classes
and i like coaching so it was something
that i wanted to try and i absolutely
fell in love with
how uh how similar was it coaching
or teaching students to dealing with
founders on a daily basis
you you know but founders have always
been
young but they were never as young as
they are
now so they required more coaching than
the founders that i worked with
that might be a little bit that might
not be as true today
but i think the founders today want less
coaching
than the founders did 20 years ago
very fair point um and so obviously at
some point you decide
uh i think you're actually still
teaching now correct i am yes
okay so you're gonna continue to teach
but uh you ultimately end up starting a
business
what was was it just pulling you out of
bed every day and you said i got to go
do this or was there some other reason
to uh
no it was really quite accidental so one
of my
responsibilities as a trustee at penn
was to sit on the endowment investment
board and
which i now chair and uh
i was sitting through a presentation on
how the endowment got its great returns
i i'm a big believer that the premier
university endowments are the best
managed pools of capital i mean that's
how your firm got started that's what
mark
did before uh he started his own firm
and uh and what i noticed was that a lot
of what they did was
all the premier endowments manage their
money approximately the same way you
know
they were all investors in benchmark and
friends of mine are on all of their
boards
so we all know what they do but a lot
of it is spreadsheet-based and manual
and i thought
god if you automate much of
what they did and if you actually
implemented in software
you could deliver an 80 20 on the
endowment experience
so it isn't quite as good but it'd be
radically better than what
the average individual investor has
available to them
in the united states and that struck me
as an opportunity because
uh when i was a venture capitalist many
of the people that i had recruited in my
portfolio companies who went on to
financial success would come to me for
investment advice
and i could never tell them to do what i
do because i was fortunate to be able to
afford
better services with higher minimums and
so
by doing this it struck me that it was
yet another social good and i had really
committed myself to social good after i
had retired
from venture capital and uh little did i
know how
how much work it was really going to
take to build that's awesome
and so talk us through in terms of as
you guys got started
um i was reading online i actually
didn't know this uh the company had a
different name at first and then kind of
the wealthfront
story started in 2011 but what was kind
of the
you know the pivot or the name change
and kind of how you navigated that and
then what was that initial
um launch under the wealth front navy
2011.
sure well everyone pivots the one thing
that most people don't understand
is that literally every single
successful technology company
ended up pursuing a business plan
different than the one that they set out
to pursue
now they all revise history because
consumers want to believe that you
always intended to serve them
so we all changed we all changed the
story
and uh and so
when we started what we what we were
trying to emulate from the endowments
was the way that they choose public
equity managers
so we built a marketplace of managers
from which you could choose
who you could access with as little as
ten thousand dollars and typically it
took
a million dollars at least to attract uh
to to be able to
get into a separately a managed account
outstanding investment manager and we
use the
methodology or algorithms that premier
endowments used to vet the managers
so what we're trying to do is find
people who are likely to outperform
and make them accessible that that's the
democratization
now what we picked were ultimately got
to a marketplace of about 50 managers
all of whom were us public equity
managers
and in the year and a half that we
operated the marketplace where we had
performance post
selection our managers outperformed the
s p
by four percent net of fees so we did a
great job and nobody cared
and and what we learned when we dug in
was that as i said we were really only
appropriate for the u.s public equity
portion of one's portfolio and when we
talk to people who chose not to open an
account the consistent message that we
got everyone use different words but
basically
we would rather that you manage all of
my portfolio adequately and
inexpensively than a portion of it
superbly
and that was a lot easier to do so we
skinned the marketplace down to one
manager
us and we offered a diversified
and rebalanced portfolio of low cost
index funds and that
immediately took off yeah that's awesome
and so
walk us through uh before today's
announcement um kind of
what the product itself looks like so
users come in
under the promise that uh you know i
think the popular terminology of robo
advisory basically the computer and the
algorithms are going to
help me um you know basically protect me
from myself
right it's gonna do things that um
normally i would
not do or i wouldn't be disciplined to
do it i don't have to think about it but
what does that look like in a product
format well basically what we've done
is taken best practices in the financial
advisory world
and automated them there's no
proprietary algorithms there's no quant
element to what we do the way that we
diversify your portfolio was
first conceived in 1958
and it won the nobel prize in 1990 and
it's the basis on which
all well-managed large pools of capital
diversify their holdings
among asset classes and there's a
tremendous amount of research
that's very consistent that shows
that they're trying to pick managers to
outperform the market is
almost impossible over the long term and
you're better off picking
index funds to represent each of the
asset classes
so basically that's what we do on
people's behalf
the way that you select the portfolios
based on their risk tolerance
and only that most people overstate
their tolerance for risk and the problem
is
that that the research is really clear
that most
individuals buy when the market goes up
and sell when the market goes down
it's the opposite of what you should do
but it's what feels right and nothing
about good investing
feels right so if we can keep you
invested
then that's going to earn you another
one and a half to three and a half
percent
per year based on the research of the
way individual investors behave
so we want to make sure that we get a
portfolio that's risky enough but not
too risky it's sort of like goldilocks
and and if we can keep you invested in
that diversified portfolio you'll do
well
so over the eight and a half years that
we've offered that service
our gross return is about eight percent
per year
now certainly people can outperform that
but i don't think very many people over
eight and a half years have earned more
than eight percent compounded
i really don't and on top of that
we deliver a service called
tax loss harvesting which
pays for our very modest fee of a
quarter of a percent
anywhere from three to 13 times over
so amazingly applying this methodology
that typically has only been available
to very
wealthy people it's selling
an etf when it goes down and replacing
it with a similar one
to maintain the risk and return
characteristics of the portfolio
that adds after tax for our average
portfolio on the order of two percent of
the portfolio value per year
but it ranges anywhere from three to 13
times the portfolio
this year the tax laws harvesting will
probably
generate a value equal to 15 times our
fee
and it's free and it's deterministic
it's not
there's no timing of the market there's
no fancy algorithm
and and so it's tremendous value
so we just kept improving it and
improving it and adding more features to
that
to the point that you know dave swan
sidney runs the yale endowment who's
probably the most famous
endowment manager a large pool of
capital manager in the world
said to me i don't think there's anyone
better than what you do other than maybe
a few of the top endowments and we make
it available to people with as little as
500
so over time the way that we expanded
was
we came to realize that our value added
we started adding planning and advice to
our suite of services
and we came to realize that the
investments that we had made in
automation
in in all the platform work because we
won't deliver a service unless it can be
completely automated and advice
automation
were the things that really stood out so
we said that our vision was to automate
and optimize
all of your personal finances and then
one of our engineers said
well that's self-driving money and
that's a lot pithier way of saying it we
said
actually yeah so the vision is to get
people to direct deposit their paycheck
with us
we automatically pay their bills and
then
uh and then even pay down their debts
and then take the remaining money
and invest that in a way that's most
appropriate for their situation and
goals
and today and so we launched initially a
high-yield cash account which was the
minimum viable product of the
account into which you would direct
deposit and then a couple months ago
we added an entire suite of checking
features
all of which are available for no fee
and all
much easier to use than a traditional
bank app
you know it's a five-star rated app on
the app store and
google play store and then today we
introduced autopilot
which is you can think of as a
software-based financial
assistant that automates your savings
and so we actually are now implementing
our vision
yeah what's really interesting about
this is um
much of i think personal finances uh
one people just are very undereducated
on it right
a lot of people just don't have either
access to the information no one sat
them down and said you know
here's the basics so i think that you
know obviously being able to kind of
impart that information uh to somebody's
portfolio whether you've got to tell
them about it or you just do it for them
is is a huge value but also the second
piece is even the people who
are educated on what to do there's still
a manual process
right in terms of you've got to go into
your account you've got to do x y and z
uh you know and it's very easy to kind
of break discipline
right oh the stock market's going up
today you know maybe i should put
a couple extra percentage points in
there or take it out or
or do whatever and so to me it seems
like what you guys are really doing is
just taking the best practice writing it
into code
and then preventing people from making
all of the classic mistakes
right that's all we do it's really
really simple you know it's really funny
people
i've seen many people write about us
that it's ideal for beginners which
makes absolutely no sense
because it's just as appropriate for
really sophisticated people as beginners
and as a matter of fact the early
adopters of almost every one of our
services
are literally the most sophisticated
people so for example with autopilot
this is a feature our first self-driving
money feature that unifies banking and
investing
so what it does is that you choose the
account
that you wanted to monitor if the
balance goes above
a threshold that you set by more than a
hundred dollars
we will set up a transfer to
an individual either savings or
investment account uh we'll then send
you an email
so that you have 24 hours to say no
so we want you to be in complete control
that's what we call an assistant not an
advisor
you're in complete control of this thing
and uh
and it basically just automates what
people
what sophisticated people normally do
and over time
will monitor more and more source
accounts
and we'll route to more and more
destination accounts
in parallel and so and in the beauty of
it is
if you bank with wealthfront all of this
money transfer is immediate we take all
the float
out of the system and so there's a
tremendous benefit from using both our
banking
and our investing yeah and
in that feature um it sounds like you
guys are
uh kind of start out with the minimum
viable product but you started to
uh expand and there's kind of a greater
vision there um
i was told that you are uh the person
who coined the term
product market fit uh i am
okay so you're going to tell us the
story of where that term comes from and
then i want to hear how you
measure internally you know do each of
these new features that you launch
actually hit with product market fit but
where did that terminology come from
initially
well as a venture capitalist i i always
spent
a lot of time trying to improve my craft
i always tried to get better and one of
the things that i did is i tried to
study
my competitors to understand what they
did really well
and the firm that i most respected was
sequoia capital i just think
they're unbelievable and i think don
valentine was brilliant
and don had a methodology that that's
very unique
to sequoia don's point of view on don
passed away in this past year
and he was probably one of the two
greatest venture capitalists of all time
john doerr is probably the other from
kleiner perkins
anyway don had this philosophy that
if a startup can screw something up they
will
because you're under-resourced you're
under staff it's not that you're not
good it's just that
you have you have so little bandwidth to
do so much you're going to screw almost
everything up
so the pull from the market has to be so
strong
for you to succeed that
that's all that matters and so don was
famous for asking this question who
cares
everything he focused on was who cares
about your product and why
why are they desperate in order for a
startup to succeed
consumers need to be desperate for what
you offer because
if there's a good enough alternative
from it from an incumbent
consumers will buy from the good enough
alternative because they trust it
why would they buy from you and so i
tried to learn more and more about this
to one of our partners
uh that we recruited a partner to
benchmark
who had don is the chairman he started a
very successful
digital video company the first big
digital video company
called cq microsystems don was his
chairman
so i tried to learn from him about don
uh
couldn't exactly got up and don wouldn't
tell you the secrets if you called them
no but i was on the board of a number of
companies we worked with sequoia a lot
back in the days when we used to
syndicate and
i would talk with my colleagues because
there was a lot of mutual respect
and so i basically put a name
to what don had been doing for decades
so it
the the idea of the market pulling the
product out of your hands
i thought of is product market fit
and so i coined the term and uh
i i really spent a lot of time working
on the concepts with mark andreessen
because
i sat on mark's board at opsware
and uh he was really interested in this
i actually gave them an idea they
pivoted from something called loud cloud
to opsware based on uh some of the
thoughts that i put together on what was
important to product market fit
and so that together we really tried to
think that through mark wrote about it a
lot which is why a lot of people think
that he coined the term but
he's always very kind to give me the
credit and about
12 years ago i started teaching a course
on it at stanford
so every year i try to get a little bit
better at
trying to understand the issues so back
to your your
key question is how do you know if you
have it i think there are different
heuristics for
uh consumer companies and enterprise
companies for consumer
companies it's exponential organic
growth
because how do you know that people want
your value proposition well the only way
that you can tell is
if you get word of mouth then the only
measure of word of mouth is exponential
organic growth
it's not growth in general because you
can gain growth you can buy growth on
economically
and so a lot of people fall for that but
one of the things that you find if you
talk to the premier venture firms
is they're riveted on exponential
organic growth
and then how about uh with the the
enterprise
software well there are two things there
are two heuristics that i've come
to recommend for them one of my teaching
partners
for another one of my courses not the
product market fit course was a fellow
named
mark leslie who founded a phenomenal
company
called veritas software that he grew to
about a billion and a half dollars of
revenue before he retired
which is an amazing accomplishment and
mark's a great leader
well he published a paper with a
stanford
graduate school of business professor
named chuck holloway
called the sales learning curve and
basically
it posited that sales has a learning
curve just like manufacturing
that there's an s-curve to selling a
product it starts out slow and then
it ramps very quickly and then it starts
to slow down again
and interestingly the first knee of the
curve
in that s where things really take off
the sales yield is equal to one
so the sales yield is the
contribution margin generated by a sales
team
as the numerator and the cost in the
denominator
is the cost to field a sales team
so for an enterprise company there's
usually a direct sales person
there is a uh an sc a
sales engineer who does the technical
part of the sell
there's often an inside sales rep or a
portion of an inside sales rep
there is the management overhead and
when you add it all up it adds up to
about six hundred thousand dollars per
team
so that says once a sales team is able
to generate a gross profit
in excess of six hundred thousand
dollars
you know you've hit the recipe you know
you've figured it out in the the
paper on sales learning curve which you
can easily google
makes the point that the biggest mistake
enterprise companies make is they ramp
up their sales teams
before they know whether or not their
sales yield is greater than one
and they do it thinking more sales reps
means more sales
well it doesn't work that way first you
have to figure out the recipe
and then you can ramp it that's where
you waste most of your money
so that's one and then the other one i
learned from doug leonia
who's the managing partner at sequoia
not surprisingly
and that is when an enterprise company
starts
it usually has to do a trial as a proof
of concept
and what you find is in order to qualify
the
the prospect you say you make them sign
a contract that says
after 30 days if the product does what
you say it will do what you represent
they'll buy the product no one ever
lives up to that contract
so what doug does is he pulls he tells
the ceo
pull the trial after 30 days now most
companies don't start the trial until
one or two weeks into the stated 30-day
period
but doug's point is if they don't scream
and pay you they were never going to pay
you anyway
because if they don't scream they
weren't desperate
and if they're not desperate they're not
going to pay you so pull the trial
now this drives entrepreneurs nuts
because they the worst word in the
english language for entrepreneurs is
maybe
maybe is no with hope when someone says
maybe they're never going to say yes
but you want them you want to believe
it's hope you want to believe they're
going to say yes
so if you pull the trial you learn
whether it's yes or no
and if it's yet if it's no then you
try to you don't just keep trying more
trials
you try to figure out why was that
customer not desperate
what are the characteristics that would
cause someone to be desperate
and you test the new hypothesis and
that's where you apply
the lean startup methodology yeah one of
the things that's really interesting
um you know again you've co-founded one
of the absolute best venture capital
firms in the world today you've built a
very big business with wealthfront
but what you're talking about when
you're talking about kind of
formulas and algorithms and things like
that is you were talking about the
decision-making of the endowment
pool managers or financial advisors
but venture capital and company building
has many of those same
you know either formulas or
decision-making processes and kind of
lessons learned over the years they just
might not be as clear because they're
not as
uh quantitative right you know they're
clearly not as quantitative
yeah but but very similar in terms of uh
if you understand this stuff it is very
easy one to recognize and then two
as the founder of a company it's easy to
focus on here are the important things
right the exponential organic growth is
much more important than going and
syncing a bunch of money into
digital ads for example i wish that
knowing how to judge
made a difference to actually creating a
product that
succeeded at those things those are two
very different
issues so
yes i have a i think i have an unfair
advantage
in knowing what to look for but
unfortunately that doesn't
help you conceive compelling problems
i i love the uh the honesty
one of the things uh that has happened
over the last
uh you know six seven months is
obviously uh
covet 19 a very large impact to
the public markets and then kind of a
macro environment that uh
i think a lot of people are just
scratching their heads right so we don't
have to get into kind of
why has a lot of this happened but
there's obviously been a lot of
volatility in the market talk a little
bit about the impact that that
volatility has had
on wealthfront users and then maybe some
of the
positive things that wealthfront has
allowed people to do that
you know data is suggesting for example
a lot of older
clients in the financial advisor world
sold stocks at the bottom of the market
in march right because of short time
horizons
so let me just talk kind of the macro
environment and covet 19
how that's impacted wealthfront okay
well
first of all yeah as context you should
know that
we target young professionals as our
customers so
uh millennials who save and so
today millennials are 25 to 40.
they like us because as they tell us
we pay you not to talk to us we don't
have any advisors
our customer support reps are licensed
as financial advisors
but you don't need them and their job is
actually more focused on figuring out
what to do to the product to keep
someone from
reaching out to them that it is
providing technical support even though
they provide great technical support so
the the thing that's most surprising
about
our customer base is our withdrawals are
not at all correlated with market
performance
this shocks people now i don't know if
that's because
they they you know we offer a passive
investing solution an index-based
solution
and maybe to use us you've already
bought into passive investing and if you
understand passive investing you know
you can't time the market so you
shouldn't try
so art withdrawals are much more
impacted by
life events like getting married or
buying a home
than the state of the markets now
the add-on deposit rate is affected by
the performance of the market and
that thing that i referenced earlier
about how people chase the market up and
down
so they don't withdraw but they can't
quite bring themselves to add more money
when the market
goes down so
we're going along just fine i mean we're
growing at our our normal pace but i
would say that
uh right now the day trading
is exploding and you see that in in
companies like robinhood
now every 15 years or so something
happens that causes an explosion in day
trading
and then people lose their money and
then they learn their lesson but you
know it's like
kids teenagers with parents no amount of
telling someone
the research that you shouldn't day
trade
is going to get them to not do it
because it's also a lot of fun
so we see people and it's really funny
that we
because people link all of their
accounts to us
so that we can automate the movement of
money and such
we see where the money is going and
they're allocating our clients are
allocating a bunch of
more money to trading which literally
makes no sense
but it's what they want to do and
they're welcome to do what they want to
do
what's so interesting to me is uh you
get the market volatility
right to your point there's probably
some longer term trends just
now's about the right time for day
trading to come back because people who
you know learn their lesson back uh 10
to 20 years ago they've kind of aged out
of the phase of wanting to do it and so
there's a whole nother crop of people
that need to learn the lesson exactly
but
but the other thing that's really
interesting is um sports
completely disappeared right and so one
of the things that
is fascinating to me is many of my
friends who were uh always betting on
sports right through
whether it was kind of the fantasy stuff
like the draftkings of the world etc
uh or just you know kind of more amateur
what's the name of the guy from barstool
sports who's promoting day trading that
you can't lose money trading
what's his name dave portnoy yeah dave
portman
you know the thing that reinforces it
too anthony is that
you know if you look at the s p since
the bottom what are we up 50 or 60
percent
something like that so so if you started
investing then
post shelter in place and you're up 30
you think you're brilliant because
historically if you're up 30
in six months you're a god
but if you're up 30 percent in the last
in the last
four or five months you're terrible
i mean you would have been far better
off buying a market index
but it doesn't feel that way i mean you
can brag to your friends i'm up 30
i'm really good at this and so i think
that has reinforced this idea that
the the other periods of great uh day
trading
coincided with very large increases
it wasn't so much about volatility it
was about a large
increase in a short period of time which
led people
who had historically reasonable
performance to think that they were
doing a good job
you know we were talking about howard
marks it before and in one of his recent
letters he pointed out
that if the s p 500 is
up 50 percent you know
the six biggest tech companies are up
more
and the other 494 companies that
comprise the s p
500 are down 10 or 15 percent
what does that tell you so if you
invested in one of those
a momentum investor to me is not a
brilliant investor
they're a lucky investor yeah well i
think also
it goes to this belief that human nature
is uh whenever something happens whether
that means prices go up or down just
something is happening uh the feeling of
control
uh unfortunately comes from people doing
things right so
it's like oh i see a price movement i
need to buy or sell because that's how i
almost convince myself i'm in control uh
and what
obviously all the research shows is
maybe being in control is not the thing
that needs to happen
right we're the boring choice
but you know the people
what all we can do is encourage people
to limit their play money to
a reasonably small percentage of their
total net worth go have fun
you know bert malkiel is our chief
investment officer and burt
invented the index fund and uh wrote the
seminal book on the subject called a
random walk down wall street
he was a professor for many many years
at princeton university
and i'll never forget soon after we
launched we had an event
for our local clients in the bay area
and we invited bert to to a fireside
chat and then
we opened it up to questions and a wise
ass in the audience said
bert do you own any stocks and bert said
as a matter of fact i do and i also love
going to the dog track
he said but i consider that
entertainment
that i don't consider that investing and
i keep it to less than 10
of my net worth i enjoy it
and i do it but i know exactly what it
is
so yeah that's a great way we're the
boring alternative
that's awesome um obviously uh there's a
lot of questions now
about 60 40 portfolio construction
uh passive investing how do you think
about
um kind of shifts in uh the modern
portfolio theory like a lot of these
core concepts that uh financial advisors
for sure
have built a lot of their business on
and done very well over the years
do you think that any of that is
changing or is a lot of that
conversation
just people basically they're wishing
that something would change
because they don't like the idea that
you know the same principles have worked
decade after decade after decade and
that's going to continue
well practically speaking i think the
latter i think that's a very good
question
uh technically speaking there have been
advances and factor-based analysis
and that's led to products like smart
beta
and there was a nobel prize awarded for
that in 2019 so
or 2013 so 23 years after modern
portfolio theory
so there are more modern ways to
construct the portfolio there are
there are limitations to modern
portfolio theory and as i said
before we view ourselves as an 80 20 on
the university endowment portfolio we're
not quite as good
but for someone with who doesn't have
the money to invest that way
you know who isn't worth hundreds of
millions of dollars i think neta fees
after taxes
nothing can come close so yeah it is
really boring to have a portfolio with
maybe
maybe not 60 40 but maybe six asset
classes in it
and the thing that we can really add
value on is the tax savings
that a traditional financial advisor
can't do because it's too complicated
you know if you think about all the tax
lots especially with dividend
reinvesting
from the index funds that
that that's too hard for an advisor to
perform other than at year end
but computers don't care about number of
clients or a number of tax lots
so we can do it dynamically every day
and that leads to far
greater value creation not because we're
so much better just because
computers are better at doing things
like that so
you know why don't advisors use really
inexpensive index funds i think they
need to try to justify their fees to
their clients
you know we only charge a quarter of a
percent and nothing for the taxal
service
but the average financial advisor
charges one percent
and if you outsource some of the
portfolio for tax loss harvesting
to parametric associates they charge
another half a percent
so people people have to justify
the fees with more action the problem is
more action leads to destruction of
portfolio value not addition
not creation of portfolio though but
that's not a fun narrative
for sure and and one of the things in
the uh university endowment so many
people listening to this
uh are probably not familiar with uh
endowment investing obviously
uh having a partner in mark yusko who uh
spent a lot of time
doing that uh i've got very well
exceptionally well yes
yeah i've gotten the crash course uh
many many times um and
for the people can uh uh go andy
mentioned dave swenson he's written a
great book about
kind of portfolio allocation and
construction
but one of the key pieces to the
endowment model
is uh the use of alternatives and so how
do you think about
uh that in a world where um
you can use quantitative models and
algorithms and uh
software really to um you know again
just
help people do the good things right not
necessarily do anything
crazy special but just the good things
where do you see the alternatives
fitting into that
well the dirty little secret is almost
no quant funds make money
and by saying almost no quant funds
outperform the market
renaissance has for decades
and everyone holds them up as an example
and maybe two sigma has as well but
i can't name more than five that
outperform the market net of fees
so logically one should be able to
create a
quant fund that that can do the things
that you say
but they can't and that's why the plain
vanilla
makes sense so and look if you have
access
to the premier hedge funds
and uh private equity firms
then there are a few that are two sigma
from the mean
you know in the venture business
something like
20 firms or three percent of the venture
capital firms generate 95
of the realized returns of the industry
now there have been a bunch of studies
of late how
they don't represent nearly as much of
the returns of the industry but the only
thing that matters are the realized
returns
markups don't matter so if you can get
access to those 20 firms
man by all means you should but none of
those firms want you as an investor
they want people who are going to be
there for decades
and where there's continuity of
management and the people are just going
to say yes
and they have extremely long time frames
and they are not worried at all about
the state
of the public markets so when they don't
want investors who when the markets go
down worry about whether or not they
should make a new commitment
so if you can't get access to the
premier hedge funds
or private equity firms you shouldn't do
it
because investing in the others are
value destroying exercises and the
number one thing
that private wealth managers sell
to justify their high fees is access to
alternatives the problem is the old
groucho marx line
never join a club that would have you as
a member if a brokerage firm can get
access
to an alternative asset the only reason
they can get access
is because they can't raise money
through the best investors
why would they accept individual
investors as investors
that's stupid so be careful
what you're being offered it's uh
it's funny to hear you say uh the
realized returns because that only comes
from somebody who has been around long
enough to see the realized returns and
understand that that's actually the uh
the ultimate goal of this game
is that you have to get the money back
exactly and
markups are great but you know there's a
lot of unicorns that won't ever return a
penny
we've definitely seen that already and
something tells me there are more to
come
uh talk a little bit about the uh
there's a counter argument to basically
what you guys are doing
uh that there's kind of the critic who
would say oh there's just this massive
passive investing bubble
now there are tons of um what i'll call
uh the uneducated critic which is just
uh kind of a
you know a swipe of the um of the brush
and just say it's all bad
then there's very educated uh kind of
critiques but how do you
see um whether there could be a passive
investing bubble
or not and how you think about kind of
navigating that
you know i draw an analogy to climate
change
if you look at the peer-reviewed
research
something like 90 98 of the scholars who
do research
agree that there is a problem with
climate change
now if you go online it's not 98
i remember in john oliver's first season
he did a bit where he said you know all
of these
uh point counterpoint news shows
have debates on the subject where they
have one person represent each side
which makes you believe that
it's a 50 50 argument he said that
totally misrepresents it so i'm gonna
i'm gonna populate my desk in the
relationship
of the actual research and so he had 98
scientists
sit on one side of the desk and one
scientist
sit on the other so among academics
there's no
debate on this topic
it's very very clear there's tremendous
debate among individual investors
because they don't want it to be true
because no one wants to believe that
they can't do it you know it's really
funny to me
that you'd never pick up a scalpel and
think
i could perform heart surgery but you
can look at a yahoo finance page and
think i can pick stocks
both of which take years and years of
apprenticeship
and learning to do exceptionally well
but for some reason people think
they can they can pick up investing
very very quickly and and i've never
understood
you know i'm a pretty good investor i
don't invest my own money
because i'm not doing it all the time
and i'm not totally on top of it so i'm
going to delegate it
to people who know what they're doing
now to address the specific point you
made
about uh is there a bubble in in passive
you know i think just last year passive
funds
total capital passed actively managed
funds
total capital you know and that's after
and i think vanguard sold their first
index fund in 1974.
so it's taken a long long time to get to
50
bert malchio's point of view and he
actually wrote a blog post about this
on the wealthfront blog was that
is that until passive is
90 or 95 we don't have any problems
because as long as there's five percent
of the market
that's actively investing you can
accurately price securities
you know think about if you have 40
trillion invested in in equities
do you need more than 2 trillion to
accurately price the security
i don't think so so that's why we are a
long
long way from passive getting in the way
of
accurately pricing securities because as
long as a security
as long as there is two trillion dollars
of money chasing it
if something gets mispriced terribly
someone's going to jump it
yeah it's funny to hear you talk about
uh the individuals who are debating
uh passive uh verse active because i
think you are right that uh
it's uh people want to believe that they
can uh
i don't blame them but i don't think i
can pick up a scalpel
and perform heart surgery
absolutely talk a little bit about how
you overcome that psychology right so
obviously you don't
okay you preach to the converted explain
that a little bit more
so the first rule of entrepreneurship is
you can only sell to people who want to
buy that
startups can't educate i have to let
vanguard educate people on passive
investing and then they come to realize
that we offer a better form of passive
because our tax loss harvesting more
than pays for our fees
so if you like vanguard you'll love
wealthfront but i let vanguard do all of
that work
i i can only preach to the converted i
can't
i can't com i can't do missionary work i
have to leave that to big companies
and that's that's not just true of
wealthfront that's true of all startups
is that a resource constraint or what
what exactly is driving takes so much
time
time time and effort got it
um talk a little bit about uh the fee
based model so i saw a couple of people
tweeted at us
um asking basically saying uh how do you
grow
aum uh is there things you can do with
the business model that could help or
hinder
uh that that growth and how you just
think about an au
aum based fee versus maybe some of the
other business models that people are
trying
but like what so well so mainly in the
uh more active uh stock brokerage right
so they'll go no fees and kind of try
other things in passive it's a little
bit harder right but but um
i hope that your viewers and listeners
realize that robin hood makes a rather
large multiple of revenue
uh relative to us annually
they get more revenue from you than we
do
for their free trading
and that's just because it's hidden it's
called payment for order flow
the exchanges are paying them to place
the trade
and the reason the exchanges pay
robinhood to place
the trade is because the exchanges
then sell that data to high frequency
traders
who front run your trade and make a
penny a transaction
now i don't understand why this is legal
but it is
but to me it's insider trading it's
enabling
insider trading so and
just so i'm clear because i actually
have never heard anyone make that
argument
it's the idea that the exchange is
selling it is the part that
um you don't like or the part where
robin hood's selling it to the exchange
or just the whole well
i i didn't say i don't like i'm just
saying that
if you call let's say i'm i'm a
brokerage phone
and you say i want to sell 100 shares
of netflix with netflix at 500
that's a lot of money so i'm just trying
to make the
this easy so uh
as the broker i then
uh electronically place that on an
exchange
for someone to buy instead of me having
to pay the exchange to make the trade
the exchange pays me to place the chain
the shares on their exchange to be
purchased
so instead of me paying the marketplace
the marketplace pays me
and the reason that the exchange is
willing to pay me
is they then take the
data the information that and they don't
know that it's andy ratcliffe they just
know
that an individual wants to sell 100
shares of apple
and they sell that to a high frequency
trader
so if the market for
uh for netflix
is a bid ask spread of
501 50 and 500
175 they'll jump
in and buy it
at 500 150
and sell it at 500 175
so before you have a chance to sell it
they know you want to sell
they buy they jump in and then they sell
it to you
and they do this in milliseconds
and so the high frequency trader
every year they get a smaller and
smaller time period
to front run your trade so
what's the name of the guy who wrote
side uh
and moneyball oh um
michael lewis michael lewis so he wrote
a great book on this called flash boys
if you really want to understand it
so that's why and so robin hood makes
all of this money
and then it really is a commission they
just don't call it a commission
and today there was a the wall street
journal published a report
that the sec is likely to find the more
than 10 million dollars
for not disclosing that they do this
yeah so what we do is we charge a
percentage of assets
which actually is a lot lower than the
fee that you're paying to robinhood you
just don't
it's just overt people don't like overt
fees
and as i've said before we feel good
about what we do because the value of
our tax laws harvesting
more than pays for that fee many many
times over and the reason that we're
able to do this
is if you delight your customer they
tell their friends
so we grow through word of mouth so i
was on the board of reid hastings
previous company pure software
and he taught me that virality is the
greatest form
that delight is the greatest form of
virality so if you delight people
they they keep giving you more money and
one of the unique things about
wealthfront
is that we our average
customer generates 30 more revenue to us
each year by one giving us more deposits
into adopting more of our services
if we were a sas company that would be
in the top quartile
they call it dollar based net expansion
ratio
and you only do it if you really delight
your customers and the highest valued
companies
are the ones that do this for a consumer
company
net of churn to generate more than 100
percent of last year's revenues
is exceptionally unusual yeah
and is this where you see something like
a netflix um
being able to increase the price and not
have increased
churn yeah because they delight their
customers they give you more and more
value
yeah it's fascinating i think that when
you start to use
comparisons on the consumer side with
the sas very quantitative model too
right you can really start to unpack i
think
hey is this working right it goes all
back to the product market fit
well it all goes back to devner all goes
back to this dollar based net expansion
ratio
you know data dog is something like uh
1.7 or 170 that means a customer that
they acquired last year
it's like same store sales the same
store sales are 1.7
x what they were last year can you
imagine a retailer
with same store sales of 170
they're happy if they get 104 and so
datadog
is something like 170 snowflake which is
coming public is something like 160
percent
the top quartile of sas companies are
125
and we're at 130. well i
i challenge you to find another consumer
company above 100.
yeah well and what's interesting too is
your model like you like you're talking
about here right so netflix has to go
and make a corporate decision to raise
prices
right and that's or they give you more
services but in the case of netflix
they don't have more services yep but
but it's just hard to do that year in
year out right there's fatigue for the
customer etc
for you guys it is based on you make
more money
as the user deposits more money with you
and therefore we make more money
with you not from you exactly by by
automating it by only delivering
services that we can
automate we lower the cost of delivering
the service
and we share the economics with our
customer and they really really value
that
so you know first we offered investment
services
and then we offered the fastest easiest
and cheapest way to borrow money
with our portfolio line of credit our
customers who use that
are our most satisfied customers then we
offered a high yield cash account it's
free
we make a little net interest margin on
it but we make money that way
then we offer checking services so with
a debit card
so we make interchange revenues on the
debit card
and then in the future we'll offer
mortgages again we'll share
the economics with our clients so
they'll get better rates
than they would from any other bank but
will still make a spread
we can do just fine with much lower
prices because of our automation
yeah i love that and the nice thing is
the autopilot
brings it all together that imagine you
know
you don't have to learn how to drive a
manual transmission or a stick shift car
before you learn how to drive an
automatic do you
you did not but you never see anybody
online
say well before you drive any automatic
you better learn how to drive a stick
but for some reason
earlier you talked about financial
education with wealthfront
you don't need any financial education
we do it all for you
we literally do it all for you so you
don't have to learn how to drive that
stick shift car
that's awesome uh the last thing i want
to talk about uh before we get into some
rapid fire questions to finish up
is uh you are very well versed and spent
a lot of time
in the endowment world so these large
pools of capital
um one of the more uh i'll call it
controversial
uh or debated topics has been uh there
are a couple of managers i think the uh
one of the nevada pension managers
uh has basically said nope i'm not gonna
play this game of
uh managing the endowment i'm instead
going to go into all low-cost indexes
right
basically he walked in and uh i'm
paraphrasing but i think he basically
fired like 90 percent of the staff
and he put it all on low cost indexes
shows up every day and like reads the
newspaper
right doesn't do too much do you think
one
that trend will become more popular at
the large pools of capital
and two do you think that maybe some
portion of what they do
can be automated so you guys should do
this for consumers today but can this
kind of go upstream to the larger pools
of capital as well
sure it's exactly what we do and it
makes a tremendous amount of sense
remember i said earlier
that if you can't get access to the
premier alternatives
you shouldn't try well guess what
the the uh the non-premier
in limited partners the non-premier
endowments or pension funds
can't get access so it's sort of a
fool's errand for them to continue to
try
it doesn't for most of them it doesn't
stop them from still investing
from getting an allocation to hedge
funds or private equity or venture
capital but they shouldn't it's
you know the the average return of the
venture capital
asset class is horrible it's really a
dumb asset class to invest in
if you can't get into one of the top 20
firms that doesn't stop people from
doing it
for ego reasons so as a matter of fact
uh we have a debate at the pen endowment
about whether or not we should index u.s
public equities
we one of the things the endowments are
good at
is uh figuring out how to choose
managers
they're in that you know two sigma from
the mean group they're
always an unusual set of outliers who
were able to identify managers who
outperformed the market
those were the algorithms that we used
when we started ka-ching
the predecessor to welfare and
and we're still really good at picking
international managers and i've been
generating alpha that way
but we haven't been at us
and so it's a really controversial
decision
should we index because you know
real real investment managers don't
index
so if it's if the discussion is going on
at the seventh largest endowment
in in the university world and one of
the best managed ones
i i think it should go on in one of the
lesser announcements
it's so fascinating to me because uh
for the most part when you bring most
money managers into a room
they're incredibly intelligent uh
they're very very
uh focused on kind of truth-seeking and
generally have sound deceptive about
themselves
well that's what i was gonna say is
basically when it comes to their
decision
it ends up being they completely throw
math out of the window right all the
research it just
it's so fascinating to me how somebody
can be so intelligent
and completely from an emotional
standpoint right off
certain conversations or certain options
uh and it's just a human thing
you know the best explanation i've heard
for why it's so hard to outperform the
market came from a member of our
advisory committee
who is a legend in the investment world
named charlie ellis
charlie founded the premier financial
services consulting firm called
greenwich associates
and for many years he was the chairman
of the yale endowment which
i think is the best managed pool of
capital he's
been a instructor at harvard and yale's
schools of management
and uh he was on the vanguard board for
20 years as well
and so the the way that he describes the
challenge is he said look
40 years ago the vast majority of the
money invested in the stock market
was invested by individuals and as i
mentioned earlier
uh individual investors consistently
and buy when the market goes up and sell
when the market goes down
so he said you can think of it like a
poker table the one
institutional investor at the poker
table with a bunch of
individual investors was like playing
poker with a bunch of rubes
all you did was take the other side of
that trade
and by taking the other side of the
trade you could outperform by one and a
half to three and a half percent
you know it's a zero-sum game the amount
by which the
individuals were losing by by chasing
the market
well fast forward 20 years and almost
all the money is now in the hands of
institutions
not individuals so now everyone at the
poker table
is a really good poker player well it's
really hard to win
consistently if everyone at the poker
table is a really good player
but it's really hard to admit when you
used to be
the star at the table that you're now
one of many stars at the table and i
think that's what leads
to that cognitive dissonance yeah that's
a fantastic explanation i never thought
of it that way
but it makes a whole lot of sense
charlie is i mean people love charlie
because he explains complex issues
so simply yeah and and i also think it's
um
you know that the other part of the
endowment model that's so fascinating to
me is
you know you don't sit at penn by
yourself making decisions
right there's a room full of intelligent
people and i love to always ask the
individual stock investor
who's your um you know kind of your
advisory board who's who's on your board
right who's on your investment team and
the dog doesn't count
and so it's just you know naturally we
get lost in our own thoughts we're very
emotional you don't have somebody there
to
to kind of talk with this stuff so i
think that um it you know it's pretty
clear it's just
do people buy in i love your idea i've
kind of only preach to the converted
yeah makes a lot of sense and people
want they want an advantage if they're
only
you know i have a friend who's a
professional poker player
and he only plays in tournaments
in out of the way places
now the the pot's much smaller but he
wants an event he wants to play against
a bunch of rooms
so he goes to oklahoma city and he goes
to and he goes to uh
you know champaign illinois he goes to
all these weird places
but he doesn't go to the world series he
plays in the world series of poker
just because everybody does but that's
not where he makes his money he makes
his money by playing against a bunch of
rooms
i have a couple of friends who who do
the same thing they're very good at
poker
uh have played professionally or online
um in kind of a full-time basis
and i was shocked when i heard that's
what they were all doing
and basically they're like look all the
money to be made is to basically find
these big fish that want to play private
games
right and they said because they got a
lot of money and they're not very good
at poker
and so you know there's a combination
it's a really good comic
only only if you're the guy who's good
at poker right
andy before i let you go ask everyone
the same two questions and then you'll
get to ask me one to uh to end it
but the first question is just what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
the one that changed my perspective
on technology was the
innovator's dilemma
theory from clay christensen is worthy
of a nobel prize
explain a little bit more why that was
so foundational or
kind of mind-changing for you
well disruption is perhaps the most
commonly misused term in technology
so clay christensen who passed away last
year
was a professor at harvard business
school and
he coined the term disruption
theory and it it had a precise
definition
unfortunately reporters and others have
come
to represent uh disruption as anything
that's new or different
but what clay found from his research
was that uh
if a company uh can come along
and deliver something that's simpler
cheaper
and more convenient than the incumbents
such that it is uneconomic for the
incumbent
to address it's an almost
impossible advantage to overcome
so there and there are two forms of of
disruption
new market disruption and low end
disruption so an example of new market
disruption
is where you serve non-consumers the
people
cannot consume the incumbent's
services so think sotheby's and ebay you
couldn't sell
you know your leftover items from a
garage sale at sotheby's because
they only sold things for 30 000 or more
now ebay was able to build a profitable
business
facilitating the sale of 20 items
now over time they were able to move up
market
and because of the breadth of their
market
they really ate into the profitability
of all other
retailers so that's an example of a new
market disruption
now it's called an innovative and then a
low-end disruption
is when you serve the over-served
in every market case people start adding
more and more features to the point that
people can't use them all you know think
about office phones
you know they're all these features on
an office phone that you've never used
so there's an opportunity to come up
with something simpler cheaper and more
convenient
a great example of that was dell with
versus compaq
when dell got started compact sold
computers
to resellers who then sold it to
companies and individuals
compact had a 40 gross margin
and the retailer had a 20 gross margin
you know resell margin
dell sold direct to consumers at a 25
gross margin now their cost of goods
sold was higher than compaq
which was a multi-billion dollar company
but not that much higher
so dell was selling computers directly
to individuals at a price
lower than what the retailer was paying
for compact
now compact could not so the problem
with a disruption
is it's uneconomic for the incumbent to
address
so if compaq tried to sell direct
they would have pissed off their channel
and lost their channel
now as a company with five billion
dollars of revenue and publicly traded
that would have destroyed their stock
price so it's called an innovator's
dilemma because you're damned if you do
and you're damned if you don't
if you ignore the innovator they move up
market like ebay did
and dell did and if you go after them
you kill your economics
so you're screwed either way and so a
truly disruptive company
that's able to deliver something simpler
cheaper more convenient
either to the overserved or
non-consumers
is almost impossible to stop
that's what netflix did to cable
companies
right so that's why it's so powerful and
and so
uh i wish i um the book came out in 97
i i retired in 2005 i would have been a
radically better venture capitalist
that i understood these issues i think
you did all right for yourself andy no
worries
uh the second question is a little bit
more fun uh
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
no none what what is the rationale for
not believing
i haven't seen any proof so
uh i've asked hundreds of people this
question and the two most popular
answers
are either uh the world is you know the
universe is so big
just probability wise i'm gonna uh throw
a flyer and say that there's something
out there
and the most uh popular no answer is
basically i'll believe when i see one
right
so it's so funny there's very few
questions you can ask hundreds and
hundreds of people
get the same answers depending on yes or
no but uh i think i'm a data-driven guy
so i want to see the data
i love that you could ask me one
question to finish up what's the one
question you have for me
what was most uh different from what you
expected in today's
discussion um
most different uh
i i don't think that i've ever heard
somebody talk
as much about obviously your background
is a venture capitalist you're going to
understand a lot of
uh kind of data points in terms of
things to look for in companies
measuring growth you know sustainable
growth versus something that looks more
manipulated
all of that is kind of expected and to
be good at it you've got to really
really understand it
i've never heard anyone talk about the
consumer metrics
benchmarking uh and no pun intended
against the
uh sass match but i mean it is a pun
intended
no but but i think that uh this idea of
like the same source sales right the
uh that margin expansion or the dollar
expansion that you talked about but
applying that to consumer businesses
uh i just had never thought of it that
way and as we were kind of talking i
started to think of you know netflix is
one example but there's actually a lot
of businesses where when you align
amazon amazon's net expansion ratio is
phenomenal
yeah and it's just aligning incentives
right it's the true measure of
if you can align your incentive with
your user that user or customer is going
to use your product more you'll make
more money but
it will actually become much more uh
valuable to them right it almost kind of
digs them deeper and deeper in and the
retention goes through the roof because
they'll never leave
yeah so this was a lot of fun thank you
so much for hosting me
listen thank you so much for spending
the time it's uh if people walk away
from this and they didn't learn
something they weren't listening so
uh i appreciate your your time and
obviously you've had a stellar career
and hopefully that will continue um
where can we send people to
find either you on the internet if they
want to ask any questions
or if they want to learn more about
wealthfront
well my twitter handle is a ratcliffe
a-r-a-c-h-l-e-f-f
and wealthfront is at
w-e-a-l-t-h-f-r-o-n-t dot com
awesome thank you so much plenty of
information there we'll have to do it
again in the future
thank you